yes can I have a grande soy milk latte  um and I'll get the egg white  um bites and I'll get an oatmeal I'll  get the um the nuts and the brown sugar  please  and the latte wonderful thank you  okay so normally I'm a whole egg kind of  girl but the egg white bites at  Starbucks they just hit different I  don't know what it is the the texture  it's just like a little cloud and I also  just find that the bacon ones are a  little bit like too salty for me I don't  eat a ton of the sugar just maybe like a  couple teaspoons just to sweeten and  adding in some healthy fats with our  nuts this little Starbucks meal here 32  grams of protein and five grams of fiber  so I feel like it's a pretty good start  to the day  good crunch